thanks for turning the road stories
podcast everybody leaving the studio
thanks for sticking around I appreciate
it we'll see you guys at the other show
bye bye podcast who went 5 minutes after
their time and service late that was
sports with balls right without balls
without mo without balls without balls
by uh Aaron ok this is starting off
weird it seems like it starting off a
little weird a little weird slow
aggressive it is a little great we're
late I can't stay in the festival I ate
too much that's why I'm aggressive I
haven't eaten anything that's why you're
so passive we need to meet in the middle
ok we'll meet in the middle this is
we're live a baby bird me maybe can i
what baby bird I think you said baby
Berton me no I think when we take off my
shirt that's a brick crusher joke
everybody all right I'm gonna put on my
cans because I can't hear you
this we're coming to you live from the
all things comedy festival all things
comedy comedy festival brought to you by
Bud Light cityscape of Phoenix and
Tito's homemade vodka
remember there was a day when we never
heard of Tito's and then the next day
Tito's was [ __ ] everywhere right
there was there was like no Tito's there
was no mesothelioma commercials and
we're super happy that they're here now
I'm just saying up not meets
mesothelioma well you're happy the
mesothelioma is no no no no not that all
right
I'm just saying Tito's mesothelioma and
Joe Bonamassa all came around the same
day and like 2010-2011 before Joe
Bonamassa and after Joe Bonamassa that's
how I live my life
but we're super glad for Tito's and Joe
Bonamassa can suck it unless he's
playing at copper blues later no do you
know Joe Bonamassa says that is any
British now with that name oh good I'm
glad you have mine I'm glad I have any
on the show but the real sponsor is
Alexander Murray in companies a 19 year
old Scotch brought to you by the man
from the mile-high show mr. Matt Santos
thank you so much sir
absolutely thank you for bringing me
this bottle of scotch my listeners know
me very well
I call it Frank that's my son's name
that's creepy oh I'm so bummed that was
not on Mike that was great but we're
having a great time with the festival
yarn absolutely absolutely we stand up
podcasts food drinks the whole nine
yards
let's just get it rollin with my guests
today a gentleman I worked with for the
first time last night on two shows was
it both shows one show he just did one
show all the way from across the pond in
West Hollywood is that where you lived
West Hollywood East Hollywood Chris
Martin right here sir rocky hello how
you doing are you a scotch drinker yeah
not as much as they're like Tito's
Tito's is my favorite again I'd never
heard of I never heard the word Tito's
that I moved to America and it's like
it's all you hear yeah everybody's gotta
have tea so I had some tea just vodka
back on I never think I've ever got to a
level with with a drink right when it's
a well it's a drink it's release like
basically disgusting to drink on its own
right I'm never like this is a great one
I mean I do you mean like I'm Neverland
this is gray vodka I'm like which one is
the least disgusting Wow I seriously
chose is like not the what it's not the
worst one I've ever had right but I
wouldn't be able to be like this is this
is well made vodka I don't know it's our
sponsor yeah but that's that's a
compliment from a British guy oh yes
look as we get we're like it's not
[ __ ]
so it's good and when it comes to scotch
I think I was telling you this earlier
like on my wedding my wife's Scottish oh
I didn't know that half Scottish half
Filipino so interesting it's just funny
when she talks I still find it amusing
sing Scottish words come out of a Asian
face the day like the day before is in
Scotland and I am I was really surprised
they were wearing a kilt
she said you
marry gonna kill and I read in one takes
I've got very small legs for a was gonna
say for a grown up for a child as small
as well but I went to the bottle shop
and I said can I have somewhere I don't
know what I thought I'm gonna have for
my groomsmen I will drink whiskey sure
when she goes like do you like get P
teach I get P did you like it smooth and
I said just give me the one that's gonna
least make me go that tastes really
strong and of whiskey but he gave me
trunk of Bell Bell Vinny at 12 any
balcony Alvin E 12 years and it was it
was wit what were you doing going this
is again not horrible right not horrible
that's my barometer and I quite liked it
so I mean I'm and I then have off the
back of it I think I started like I
don't know why so getting buying a bit
of whiskey and scotch and then I'd come
back from a gig I'm Hannah was asleep
and I'd drink it from the TV to feel
like I'm a much more professional person
right yeah but I don't what I've worked
out with it so I think one's alright if
I have to I go absolutely bananas like
it's like it's like a drug right well
yeah here's the deal I I love scotch and
I can drink beer I know where I'm at the
whole time yeah I can drink vodka I know
where I'm at the whole time scotch
as much as I've enjoyed scotch it's one
glass can be too many or three glasses
can be too many there's never it's it's
one of those where you're like okay I'm
done tonight but it's like the
percentage right that's what confusing
me cuz that 40% so like it's vodka like
40% as well no anybody's not dissimilar
yes it's the same but I've had like I
can't be just like have like I kind of
like five vodka sodas and be pretty okay
but I think about five that's a Brit
talking is that that's not load is it
although I'm no John it is America you
guys Freeport in America on my birthday
to be fair I was having mocha sodas and
and I vomited heavily like in LA because
I forgot you guys freep always we have
to give set measures oh yeah we'll go
we'll get too overexcited okay but and
with whisk it always it's like this
extra thing and it's um it just sends
you this one smells like it's not it's
quite nice actually it's 19 years old so
Cheers hello I had
that's really nice it's nice it does it
doesn't taste her it's quite smooth okay
you know it doesn't taste like horrific
ly aggressive like some of these things
can taste like I'm pretty sure that's
really good yeah they were belleve any
know much better in burning as well but
this so this is so this is this is a
this is like worth a lot more is in like
that is in you get what you pay for this
yes absolutely absolutely
thanks [ __ ] good I would I remember
when I you know my listeners know I had
braces and when I got braces on I was
that the Palm Beach Palm no Palm Springs
improv I'm pointing at Graham who's
coming on the show in a second I don't
know why I'm making him sit over there
for all this
he loves Palm Springs Palm Springs
improv and I ordered a scotch and the
bartender in the palm that you only work
at once a year and the bartender is like
oh he got braces on last year since I
saw you I'm like yeah he's like this is
a this is a scotch bother you when you'd
with your with your braces I'm like no
why would it do that and I took a sip of
scotch and found all the cuts in my oh
yeah now my you know it's when you first
get the braces they Nick up you're the
inside see I don't tell you that the
author don't know it will affect your
whiskey drinking I guess you got other
things to think about but this is this
is really tasty
Wow thank you I'm sorry our next guests
won't be able to enjoy it yeah you got
this guy doesn't need any introduction
it's my good friend Graham Elwood come
on everybody right here Graham do you
know Chris this festival you made this
time
yeah so presumably your teetotal rather
than you hate whiskey you were just like
if it's Tito's I'm having it but no yeah
I used to drink I used to love scotch
I used to love my my dad actually turned
me on to nice single malt scotch and
then I went to a scotch tasting in
Chicago that was sponsored by Johnny
Walker so I found out the history of our
scotches made okay and this single that
the sherry wood casks and the whole
thing and I was like I really I really
look I was actually just sitting back
there going oh yeah I don't miss
drinking I don't miss hangovers I don't
miss the trouble I got into but manse
some of us carry some it's Jonah is it's
that poetic thing where you easily the
history of it and you feel like I'm like
I'm intellectual pisshead so getting the
same end goal as they was like um you
don't name your next album intellectual
but we m4 my mates tag do bachelor
parties you call it we did this whole
whiskey tour and you can kind of go
around the person's telling you about
the mall and you're kind of good but all
you're thinking is can we just can we
just eat just drink the whiskey now
that's all you're thinking at the end of
it you do feel like I've learnt I've
learnt drinking like I would like do it
like you could just have a glass and
just sort of nurse it yeah do that and
smoke cigars yeah I like I looks like
like coming home after a gig at like you
know one o'clock in the morning and just
just a wine down yeah you know just plop
in front of the couch catch whatever
TiVo you are and just wine down I'm a
big fan of that yeah absolutely
wait to go to bed at the stray after a
gig even if it's been far away
I always said try and even know you guys
should go to bed now something about it
you feel like otherwise I've just gone
straight to sleep after well I can't the
adrenaline kind of keeps me off a lot of
times yeah you can't shut it down you
can't put your brain down no matter what
yeah that in poker I can't go to sleep
after I play poker use my brain go you
good at poker I used to be a rooster I
used to kind of supplement my income for
a little while playing poker because I
was speaking some about to everybody
because obviously I used to do when I
was at 18 in the UK it was a big boots
on TV sure yeah but then did you do it
from in kind funny when it's still legal
and then you had to stop when it became
illegal to online or no I still have
there are some online sites you can get
onto yeah yeah but I started before the
boom like a year sorry I think Jimmy
Schubert comedian Jimmy Choo were told
me if you're gonna work Vegas don't
gamble cuz you blow your money learn to
play poker yeah because you can sit
there and gamble for hours and ya lose
50 bucks yeah and there's no house
advantage or anything like that so
that's when I started that's when I
started playing and then anything
started but then I stopped because I
just don't I got invited to Kevin
Pollak's game a few times and that's
just a big money game and if I'm not on
my game I don't want to go so good you
know what I mean I don't want to go know
what you're doing in those big game yeah
yeah because it's like it's him it's
who's the guy whose tankers area hank
azaria is in that game the cleaner the
simpsons what's his MP who was in the
wreck and he goes that's it he's
bluffing he's bluffing he's gone he's
gone full of poo three every once in a
while he'll Henckel bust into a Simpsons
character really just on the side just
like you know they're not like guys I'm
gonna do you know everyone's he'll just
bust into some fishy I love it when I'm
a bennyboo is a very funny Australian
comedian who's sort of retired to become
a professional monk that's like a whole
different story but he him he was
supporting Michael Winslow
you know police academy he's a really
nice guy but he em it's that really
funny things like impress impression no
hangs are is not impression right he has
a lot in his artillery but here guess
it's that one can meet you
like in all these intellij you go say
you Joe he'll be hanging out Michael
Winslow he's really nice guy and he'd be
like Michael winds are just as loads of
like noise like always doesn't noises it
embarrasses all the time like Tourette's
II almost and at one time they were like
he was just like they were sitting
around him and another comment like can
you do your transformer he just looked
at him like he was like upset like he
just and but then like five seconds
later was doing it like a dog noise like
they just doesn't do requests he's like
he's like a really like like a valued
DJ's like not only request guys I'll do
whatever noises I want to do I'm not
doing transformers but I'll do a guy
walking in snow all right I got it I
gotta talk about this because this is a
great festival they all think Scott my
festivals fantastic I mean it's such a
blast so much fun the shows have been
incredible except the second show last
night at Tempe Oh what happened we my
first show which was awesome first show
was fantastic everybody it was great
the first show was great second show
just almost as packed a little real
quick Jamie flam just walk Oh Jamie's
family hello Jamie flam with his new
endeavor what's it called dynasty
typewriter theater in
[Music]
Westlake between Koreatown and downtown
awesome now they can but we're gonna
kick starter what is it
dynasty typewriter calm huh and Chris
Chris we met Mary melts Chris Martin but
we never met hey man where we grab Jaime
flame on soon to talk about the the new
theater and the projects and everything
and we know Jaime from the flame jam
shot podcast excellent
next time we were talking we're just
about to talk about this is actually
show you because you do you think it was
III need to have that as a frame of
reference I've it was quite fun but you
did get you were unlucky in terms of
those a guy he was a bit right well the
first show the first show was amazing
was great a great crowd it was packed
energy and it was just like every comic
just crushed yeah cuz sometimes you look
at a lineup and you're like man 9 acts
we're all doing like 8 to 10 minutes or
something like it was tight and you're
wondering like woo crowd was like down
with what everybody was absolutely
didn't care about the quick gear shift
of different acts sure sure and so it
was like man that was great everyone's
like it was the coolest thing ever and
then I left to come hang out over here
at stand-up live and then you did I did
the second show the 10 o'clock show
where I met Chris Martin no you went on
before me I think I went on just offed
yes out yes Sean round yeah your
deception I'll tell you about my fairly
early well no I was like first of all
they're like 12 comics on each show not
9 so I must have been like 7 yeah yeah
and all quality acts all quality show it
wasn't like this was a sketchy show or
anything like that everyone you know the
audience was having a good time
everybody's having their a little
tighter than the first one but the first
one I felt was above average audience
yeah this is an average you know this is
a typical fine excellent crowd everybody
had a good time I go up there I do one
joke about being a stay-at-home dad
some guy finds it offensive in the
audience and I can I couldn't
understand what he was saying and it
caused a big disruption at his table to
where I had to go what happened over
here
did I just cause a divorce in your
what's going on and then he started you
on that like started yelling out at me
to where I just I made that click in my
brain where I'm like for the next seven
minutes I have to destroy this guy
because he wasn't shutting up and it and
that's what I just what I did I didn't
do it like [ __ ] you know I did it
hopefully very clever I think that I
think the audience really enjoyed it but
it was like just out of the blue yeah
and then he got booted him and his whole
table booted so basically I did six
minutes and had seven people booted in
those cities you did it was like a from
my perception was like there was nothing
you did you like he was just drunk
shouted something it was annoying you
know it's someone's chant you can't hear
what they're saying something like then
he kept doing it but then you just yeah
you like said you never were like overly
aggressive you like fun with it and you
weren't like get him kicked out but he
was just being an art and so it was like
fun it was like also you know I thought
energized the crown again but it was
like that point in the show something
differents happening right yeah always
this guy's going up doing that bit
something different happened you've
dealt with it nicely and then like you
said use one with the flow yeah and I
always trade it whenever I had have to
attack a heckler I always try to defuse
it by like and I did this last night I
walked over to the other end of the
stage he was on stage left I walked over
the other than right I go I know you
guys are having a good time but this
guy's gonna kick my ass in the parking
lot later you know just give him a
little like yeah maybe I will
you know just kind of give him a little
bit and then I appreciate his [ __ ] on it
was like I know you probably cuz you
like oh it's annoying when but maybe
it's like a UK thing like that happens
sometimes like you did two shows it's
kind of I got to do something different
than a second show you did it good so
that's why I thought it wasn't yeah it's
like I had a really good time slamming
on the guy sometimes I'm like annoyed or
mic just how can be quiet
yeah but other times I'm I'm like that
was actually that was fun cuz I I did
the show in Tokyo a year ago and it was
at this dislike pub you know there's no
full-time comedy club I know of in Tokyo
so it's at this like pub and it's a
British pub but I think I was it was a
pretty an American than a British pub
anyway so it's a place where expats go
right
and he like hey let's screen earbuds and
then do the show so and they put up
local acts in front of me and then I
went up there and I was doing 45 50
minutes or whatever and there was a guy
from some I can't remember where he was
from like Holland or something but he
kept yelling out and I slammed him
mm-hmm
and then he wouldn't let go and so I'm
doing a headline set and after a while
it got [ __ ] I was annoyed and I
crushed him and I everyone thought it
was funny and I remember my girlfriend
at time was with me she's like that was
awesome and I go do you think that was
fun for me it kind of wasn't like it
became unfun after a while sure what
someone's a jackass and you just hammer
um great right in his 7 8 minutes set or
whatever fine but like after a while I
was just like I've already crushed you
ten times yeah why are you that's when I
have to get kicked out yeah yes it's
it's like yeah you get to that point you
like yes seven minutes is kind of a fun
different than video for you because
then you can't even you go into a bit
yes it's pretty show right when there's
tension you know timing and so that's
when I'm with you that's annoying for
I've I had a group of and I'm pointing
at you even though you're not Australian
but you have an accent well Australians
were originally British oh yeah so I
stole some bread
apparently Wikipedia the real sorry but
I think that you know they would convict
subreddit sure anyway my country again
being evil bastards but with a bit of
charm behind it so we get away nobody
hammers us for it anyway sorry but they
were they were there you know typical
Ostrow you know drinkin and booze and
and they came at me and the more I came
at them the more they loved it so the
more I slammed in their like again and I
was having a good time but then I
noticed the audience was kind of like
mmm you know what we didn't come here
yeah this so I had to switch gears to
shut him up and they wouldn't shut up
and then I said I I leaned over to one
the audience member I said you know what
they're just convicts from the UK they
don't know how to deal with it and then
they like yelled out again and I said
you guys already got kicked out of
England so if you don't be quiet you're
gonna get kicked out of a comedy club
now this rooster and I just left that's
great that's but that's like an
Australian brush a mist to someone who's
had dinner with I was like heckling in
the UK and Australia it's like it's just
like it's sort of thin as banter yeah
over here oh and if someone shouts out
it's like you can go [ __ ] you in the
crowd yes but in the UK and a bit
Australia it's like if someone comes at
you they come at you like over five
times I think then the crowd are like
but they come at you once or twice
they're just like right house it's got
dealing with and I bet those guys
afterwards I mean like I was helping you
out here's something I want to know
about over here which I haven't done yet
and like in the UK I did a black sir do
you have your own black circuit gigs
over here what are black circuit but
urban urban urban rooms like you call it
was like a black circuit in London I was
basically a black crowd yeah yeah no but
you've got you call it what do we call
it black rooms we've got mixed nuts on
Pico Josh wolf everybody Josh whoa I'll
see you at the punchline next week oh
yeah I go next week but I'll see in two
weeks Josh well thanks for stopping by
nice see you uh give they call them
urban rooms to not sound racist
yeah but it's not racist to say black no
no anyway not in a room full of white
people what's up just walked into the
racist podcast how you doing everybody
yeah I did this black circuit gig in
London and I'd done like two or three
and I'd gone like really well I've been
like I was kind of new I was like the
white guy and just playing up to it when
I did this one show these guys are like
can you on the end and I had another
show in London I'll go I'll go at the
end they gave me a hundred there's like
a hundred pounds I gave it to me in my
hand before I what as I walked in the
building and the hind side should have
just you turned and left because it was
Sunday night four hundred people in this
club which have heard from other acts in
black acts telling me like that's not a
good gig it's like Sunday and the crowd
are quite young and they don't drink and
this is kind of weird there was this
black act on who I've never seen do
anything but destroy every gay but he
was like struggling this is weird
and then I bumped into a guy and we used
to play sport with like twenty ten years
earlier who was doing like a rap rapping
for two songs okay
and they were kind of alright with that
no one at the ends I'll just do my stand
up and the crowd are not laughing at any
of my jokes and then someone heckled and
what I notice about this gig is this
girl was like heckling and the garnish
wasn't being like funny with it he's
just being so mean the crowd were like
loving it they were like loving just
like being not even like witty just like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] anyway so this woman like
pipes up to me and she had like a little
pointy hooded thing on and I said the
first again when I was at IU
you look like an African druid because I
look like a druid and I think that is
withing those keys we're like Caribbean
[ __ ] on Africans and they love it and so
it's an African drew it in a crowd like
I was like this is I mean in my head I
was going like the closer to racism I
get here that the potentially the more
laughs I'm gonna get but then as I can
like a slippery slope I'd rather almost
die and then I said something I had this
joke about the reference African again
got a massive laugh and I was a [ __ ] but
then I was like I'm gonna play it safe
and not just be a Fed so then ended up
going I'll go back to my normal shtick I
wish I just if I just came this woman
for 10 minutes it would have been like
yeah yeah carry down the shoulders and I
got to the end of my set for the next
five minutes Justin gear - nothing -
silence I do my last joke which had a
stupid punch on it was about if ever
someone breaks into my house I'm gonna
I've already planned in my head what I'd
use as a weapon I'd smash a clock on
their head and say like don't be alarmed
it was like a silly would you normally
work and I did it to my 40 people
absolute silence and a one guy at the
back of the room Chad
punchline - silence walked off - silence
I heard I've never I had a chance to
perform in England earlier this year but
I wasn't able to I was over there my
wife was over there for the BAFTAs yeah
so it wasn't like hey enjoy your BAFTAs
I'm gonna go do this okay whatever but I
hear like the heckling over there is can
is almost like a sport yeah it's I think
it's that yeah people whenever you'd
like do interviews over there below oh
how do you worry about heckles or dill
pickles and you just kind of get it's
like anything I think you get more
confident you're up there it's the same
thing so I'm sharing and just roll with
it but yeah like
late-night gigs packed room you're
always gonna get it's that I guess it's
more like joining in people after they
think they're helping and you know it's
often not borrow it's a it's rarely of
malice like I'm sure no one ever I think
they think it's a it's just like it's
it's just banter I mean those are for
the audience in live here a heckle isn't
always you suck is in my fact it's
rarely a you suck yeah it's usually
something trying to be helpful or
something to encourage yeah that's what
yeah my favorite one I hear more and
more so now it's not even a haircut just
happens in like clubs we hear like
you'll say a line and then someone all
like and then we laughter and someone
was out loud repeat your punchline to
their friends those trying to take
credit for it yeah yeah biscuits and you
like so loud this in the room and I'm
like friends by saying it but yeah
you're right it's really people always
going on what's the worst heckle
thinking weirdly one that's all which
ones can t deal with someone literally
just scared like your [ __ ] at comedy
that would have to be quite haunted but
no one ever shouts that right right have
you so hard to do have you ever I got a
it was either a you sucker you're not
funny once really and he wasn't wrong I
was I was tanking I was not running but
that's the only time have you ever
gotten well then I've ever gotten just
flat-out used like I'd always be spend
some like see I'm trying to be trying to
add in or some like yeah it's usually
dad it's usually somebody trying to
participate that just yells out
something that's just [ __ ] clunky and
right one time one time I was in the
comedy cafe in Milwaukee like back in
the 90s and there was this guy and he
was at a table and it could tell he was
he's the funny guy whatever dumb job
he's got I mean so he thinks I could do
that he's got that mentality he's wrong
and he said something like your sister
and his table laughed but nobody else
did and I said well I said something
like well that's too bad for you because
my sister's got the clap and the [ __ ]
cloud blew up and then I started
slamming it more and he was just sitting
wide I kept every but that was the
closest I can't ever yeah I've never had
a flat out like you say I don't think
that's that's not it it's rare that it's
just you suck it's usually like it's not
malicious it's like what you said
yeah yeah I remember one of the most
frustrating heckle and it wasn't me who
got it was the guy behind me and this is
this how he the one guy used to respond
to respond to dollars jokes that'll work
after every after I mean you could just
see the guy just the comic was just
losing his pacing yeah but have to slam
someone who's not being mean yeah just
having a good time in a [ __ ] bizarre
way funny like you just the laughter
implies that say the word funny what was
I find my favorite ones when it's it's
not even a heckle it's someone's just so
honest about how they feel about
something like I've never seen this guy
this show I won't know he's a British
coin that he was trying some new stuff
and it was like they're like brownie
jokes like combo and then he had like
jokes and if you do jokes it's great but
if you're just like chatty comic nago
here's some jokes [ __ ] cheesy write
it one it was a he did the third one and
it's put it would like no one laugh and
one one went seriously you know that was
funny you thought that was worthy of
saying out loud do you know what though
when you said you went in Japan that
really remind me I feel like expat
audiences are one of the most can be the
most frustrating crowds because you
they almost I find ex expat kind of odd
anyway in terms of they've I feel like
have you murdered someone is that why
you moved to try to run you're right or
something what could you not make it in
your own country so you've though they
always like convince you that it's great
like you know what girlfriends thirty
years younger than it's like alright
yeah anyway but you always go around
yeah well there's a lot but it's just a
lot of that and it's always like very
but i am i did some i did a show in Bali
in Indonesia like it was they'd had a
bombing there in Bali yeah okay tal I
know we know Bali yeah receivers are you
surface great okay so I was over there
versus who's the better one we're both
servers cool but if one of us is just
American one upmanship don't and I'm
insecure yeah or as you guys would say
Murray's just being a [ __ ] mark who's
one open me now it was in Bali and
there's the first show they've done
they're like seven years they've been
some bombings they're like him and he's
in this restaurant and the guys running
and really nice guys they run another
show Jakarta which is great but there's
a first on they're done in his island
and I was there with Jones had Alexandra
New York yeah I don't know I don't know
a person anybody knows yeah he's great
he just fine Gaffigan yeah he works
pretty good he's so funny and it's like
um he he's been on like I think just a
Letterman and he was over doing like a
tour of Asia and he was headlining I was
opening and the two guys that run the
gig normally great but then they had
this third kind of point guy who was
lived on Bali and had sorted this venue
out and him and his mates on this table
and they like obviously come they had
that real alpha like we're like from the
UK and I think I was Scottish and they
were just dicks right and this guy who
they were there to watch there mate and
they were there just bait might be like
good-hearted heckling mean like I went
on and they said some just rc7 I think I
- the battery's running Ted was on and
they said cleaving and she's been on
Letterman they're like he's like being
described as a new Seinfeld or some of
them some was like Seinfeld's bear might
really mean [ __ ] and again he dealt with
it and then their mate was on they only
laughed at him and he did like literally
verbatim stolen routines oh really
Robert verbatim like word for words like
this is great Australian comical Steve
uses great routine about how being gay
is more
straight than being straight it's an
amazingly dumb regime but you know he's
watch someone just doing it [ __ ] and he
was he was doing it and he dropped he
said like racist words anyway they were
laughing at him though dicks anyway my
mate Benny who I mentioned earlier
Australian coin he was going to do the
gig like a couple months later and I
said the gigs cool but just saying I
like sports like the guy running it's
odd the guys got the van and his mates
of decks like hecklers and and I emailed
him like I'd like the next day off he'd
done it how was the gig and he goes yeah
yeah the gig was all right but then you
know that guy who'd said his mates say
yeah it's through limes at me for my
whole set times they threw limes the
fruit limes at him on stage doing it
through limes at me I was like this is
this is dog [ __ ] and then they said the
chant of the bloke he was mate and the
guy thinks that aids is a made-up
disease really yeah cause he had sex a
lot of prostitutes and in his head he
thought that HIV was a made-up disease
also good guys yeah but yous go ahead
and give us that information that's why
that brings us to a question we asked on
the show what has been thrown at you on
stage I've had a shoe a shoe a shoe at a
Christmas show I wasn't at me it was a
Christmas shoe that was me I was an elf
no I was on stage in here an elf chapter
sure me I was in Brighton on stage and
some drive winner Brighton you've been
to Brighton yeah that's South England
it's nice it's the gay capital of UK so
I was there just to clarify that I got a
shoe thrown at me by some women on stage
Oh women's shoes but it wasn't like sexy
it was like just like they thought was
funny to throw shoe when is a shoe
thrown at you sexy
yeah there's never a time when sec oh
yeah if she's only wearing a shoe and
then that's the last item but she was
wearing over clothes yeah no it wasn't
definitely it's never been sexy having a
shoe thrown inflate the perception when
I was chief stone assured me I must be
in there she threw a punch I think I'm
in there I've asked you this question
but you I've only had one like someone
threw like a balled up napkin or
something and it was like fond of the
show is kind of getting rowdy and
through that and when that happened I
just went anyone throws something at me
one more time I will end this [ __ ]
show and I will come into the goddamn
audience I am not joking at all and
everyone got wide eyed and I said see
I'm not [ __ ] around I'm up here all
alone you throw something at me my life
feels threatened I will come after you
and I took us I go everybody good then I
went into my act grandma is a wig game
has a race the way it game change it's
true though there's there's an in a
surfboard there's a stringer it's a
piece of wood that goes right through
the middle of the foam Graham has a
stringer rage it's like right in there
it doesn't come out often if I feel
threatened I'm like that's that yeah if
you if there's like haha okay that's
quick but if you like if there's some
type of threat to me then I'm just like
then I will change and go I had to do it
I told this already story I'll show ya
the Tahoe show where the guy was like
really are you saying stupid stuff and
then he looked like he was gonna welcome
stairs because there was a stair yeah
yeah and I was like and then I was like
uh-uh
cuz he was pacing around I'm in Nevada
he probably owns a gun yeah and I was
just like nope cuz then it's just like
the reality of the situation is I'm on
stage all alone with lights like um it's
me against 300 or whatever and then I
just changed my physicality changes to
where it's just like just so you know I
will not go down without a fight I will
land something on you you might knock me
out but I'm good and you just need to
make that decision for yourself so I've
just I just don't I don't [ __ ] around
with that I don't know why I just it's
the guy just walked in this is a comedy
podcast so my gladiator
doing stand-up and how violent it is
you've never been no one that knows no
one's ever storm the stage and you being
on no no but this got this guy that the
Tahoe story that I told the guy was
pacing around and I just stopped him
when because it was joking and I kept
making front of him the audience
couldn't tell and I think some audience
people do that they're a good plant no
he's a [ __ ] psychopath like I was
asking I was literally going it's
security in the room I was saying this
where is the casino security and the
other
comics were just watching and then later
were like man that was nuts and I said
did you go grab security when you were
watching me no I did I'm not naming
names but Andy wood who I was giving
guest spots to all week and I go
[ __ ]
get get get a brothers back cuz that's
the thing and I think that's like a road
comic thing you know you you would bond
with guys on the road especially when
you're doing your first starting out
you're doing one-nighters and you are
summe sometimes are great but sometimes
it's you against that town sure yeah and
the minute you were always at each
other's back so if a guy was on stage
and that shit's going down the other
comic would go hey you this [ __ ] this
guy like you want to jump and do it you
wouldn't just sit in the balcony and
watch ya know that was amazing like cuz
I was literally and then I'm on stage
because then I'm jumpy and in this
[ __ ] crazy country where everyone's
shooting everybody I'm just like I'm
[ __ ] like yeah what what's gonna
happen yeah I hear rustling to this to
my stage left we're back stages and I'm
just like is this guy gonna come [ __ ]
steamroll me and I'm like where's hotel
secure I was like I feel I was like this
is [ __ ] up so I just changed my
physicality my demeanor and I said sir
cuz I do like a joke in my act about
being a yellow belt in karate I said
that's a joke I'm actually a black belt
if you come at me I will take it as a
threat I suggest you leave and the
audience was like there's just a this is
the thing that's happened to me twice
where I've had to do that and like to
suddenly put on like that's good talk
that I would be like this gonna save you
come eh that's if you just like put it
in a category like that like this guy
yeah you know how to fight yeah that's
what that's what my martial arts
instructors told me if someone comes at
you tell them you go you just get four
guys acting this way just this how you
defuse it you go I don't want to fight
you but if you come at me I will take it
as a threat and I will defend myself as
such and then they just oh cool there's
some three chests and while they're
backing out it's like yeah I just punked
you [ __ ] in that st. that's a problem
with clubs and casinos cuz the casino
security is in the casino yeah I think
it was the same club happened to me some
you know what's that shitty t-shirt
company
addicted or whatever Oh flexion
affliction affliction yeah yeah yeah
affliction guy nobody has a shirts on
okay good to to a Brit explain it is
this like a just it's just crappy Brian
it's like tap out shirts like movies
like hey I'm hard because I'm wearing
this yeah they like Kardashians and I'm
with you know stuff right Santa's you
know I'm saying like so he's and he's
all like you know just like buffed out
yeah he's got his trophy wife on her arm
and I said something like geez and she
goes that's my line like what do I say
ah geez I'm like [ __ ] we all say aw
geez okay well I got a catchphrase
hey you I wrote that hello that's mine
as well and then so I go to defuse a
situation like oh man good luck you know
dealing with her or whatever ha ha and
then he's like I'll mess you up like
that and so I go hey buddy where I'm
kidding we're all having a good time
he's in like a second row so I go to
give him like a like kind of like a side
5 yeah and he goes he's like smiles and
goes to give me the side 5 and then
grabs my hand and Yanks me almost off
stage and that was when I was like
security Livi hanging now doing worse
I'm trying if I've ever had that because
you obviously if you get attacked on
stage it's terrifying but you know like
Jim Jefferies you know that kind of did
wonders for his career really say he the
thing obviously I don't know this he's a
great comic anyway Jimmy Aries and he
you know he's always got great stuff and
especially ever he's doing great
but the thing that kind of tipped him
over in the UK it's funny I only kill
much because of that happened you know
that bill burr got booed in for the
Delphian that was great comic anyway and
that's just that something that extra
boost right after gym is on stage of the
comedy store in Manchester and his agent
Brett Vincent who is a well known agent
and great Brett Brett way but Brett no
because what Brett did Brett put this
online and I don't know if he did it
tactically whatever the Jim was onstage
in Manchester and this guy just mid show
came on and just gone side and punched
him
amid gign and Jim went off and and came
back and carried on the Crowell a true
behind him didn't have five minutes in
round but that was like that feels that
was one of the first like I don't mean
was that ten years ago so when YouTube
was that was big and I just catapult him
because he's kind of edgy anyway game
pumps on stage like validation and that
that was like a nice little boost to his
thing but I'm just just to confirm I'm
not saying cuz of that right it's now
famous I think he's a great comic
anywhere but that something like it
might just getting punched in the face
does wonders for your crit normal to
thought that like Graham goddess name
just videotaped it instead of just watch
the now would have been really happy
been short if you even showing Sean's
been shot on the stage so if you could
get don't say that yeah yeah I don't
know she would right now I don't want to
go down this path but I think about that
almost every time I don't like having my
back to the window right now yeah it's
very Italian of you I like facing the
exits but I think I think about it I
think about that I think about you know
that could go down in a club any at any
time yep I think about that a lot if I
get on yeah in England we don't have to
be worried someone Chuck a bit bread at
you know some limes that's the worst
okay no shoe so you might get shot here
by still that so although not that I you
just make it a little more pansy ish I
had a woman just like take the you know
this awful comedy club drinks with the
whipped cream on it yeah yeah she like
finger spooned it and flicked it at me
and I didn't know it and I was wearing a
tie and I'm like right on my tie and I
was going on notice I didn't know us the
worst I didn't notice and I was going on
I'm thinking I'm killing because but
everybody's laughing at the big spooge
of whipped cream on my tie
but then my buddy like came out and it
was like get her out of here she threw
something on stage yeah he came out and
it wasn't and II would obviously haha we
serve under the bus I'm good I had I had
one once where I was on stage and I was
like a bachelor party and they're all in
a jockey outfits and this is this may be
sums up the hold on a second she would
call it jockey do you know what the word
jockey means like riding a hole right in
a horse and they were dressed as jockeys
why because it's like do you not have
that
the party who ever just dresses cheap no
there's a lot of Americans laughing me
know by that I'd buy that just just let
you know so England like you always it's
not people aren't always dresses a
jockey but it's like it's it's fancy
dress so it's like do you guys for
bachelor parties do fancy dresses that
not a thing like people dress like they
bet the bachelor dresses like a massive
baby they put them like a nappy and
you're mad dummy or like a man maybe
some words we don't understand we're
like matching suits maybe oh okay then
this is different so Hallowell we have
penis straws yes oh that's for girls so
in the UK like if you're like a low-rent
bachelor party they'll be either
matching t-shirts with the guys like
with their nicknames and about like
shagger and like dude Americanized that
that's known as the shag shaggers yeah
yeah go compared to dude right so
there's that level of it or there's um
they'll dress you'll make the dress the
stag up looking like an [ __ ] so it'd
be like most of my major was like you
just go out and I sit a mic for my one I
don't want to be I don't want to dress
up and so I can prick I don't look like
an idiot on my I don't mind having fun I
don't dress up as something put someone
like a diaper and dummy in a mouth or
like a mankini different Bora yeah so
you know that green like there was a
after that film like every [ __ ] stag
do there was a guy in there and it just
looks and hen do's do a similar they
will dress sort of like Hindus so hen
doze is a bachelorette party so this is
gonna be so English right now no I'm
gonna I'm gonna sing God God save our
gracious Queen the only thing I
understood I think everything I'm trying
to explain gets more and more English
I'm not a guard understood was mankini
mankini we call it so we call it stag
and hen do is our bachelor and
bachelorette party it's called stag like
a like hen like I don't know man dude EU
yeah oh yeah do hand somebody just turn
the lights out sexy somebody heard you
talking [ __ ] about Hindus and yeah
yeah everywhere everywhere woman get
might as a red dot on there for ya
what's happening anyway so it's
fancy-dress essentially is a loose but
you know not everyone does it anyway so
this particular one they're all in a
jockey outfits and the stat the main the
bachelor you know this is hard work well
but I know it's fine yeah puts up the
bachelor and remember lift is elevator
when you get to that part of this story
yeah exactly yeah that I start coming be
they were heckling and I was it was kind
of good nature but then I started
slamming them and it's fine then the guy
I said you know you can just feel them
getting annoyed and in the main bachelor
he had like a little like a like a fake
hobby horse hobby horse they go so
anyway I started giving him a call that
Carly like doodle-loop
yeah yeah we call it a Muslim we call em
Muslim riding a Muslim to the stage
anyway he rides this he gave some [ __ ] I
could feel him like um like getting
annoyed and any he came up to the stage
like right under the middle like there
was a little gap like this before the
front row came up be like like rode it
up like pretended to ride it but still
angry like rode it angrily up to me and
like was that there and then you know
you have that thing about a little bit
of adrenaline you got haha you're trying
to be funny of it you're like it's this
guy she's guy gonna give me and then I
saw had to explain that it was just
banter and it was just drunk so he
thought I was like I don't know just
being mean it's fun he was like still
staring at me and then the crowd I come
about how I diffused it but it end up
being diffused and then I could have
seen his eyes he was like okay cool I'm
cool this but what I really liked about
it was at the end of it he then turned
to the side and then just rode the horse
back to his friends afterwards he just
rode it back he just carried on in
jockey character the whole way that's
really I never even realized that that
you guys don't dress up like wankers for
your room
sorry [ __ ] for your dress up
like wankers I love you know I love
seeing his American guys in a in like
sleeveless basketball tops on a night
out
like and I love you got a backwards
baseball cap on and that's wicked and I
love it but I thought I was just in like
movies I didn't know like when I was in
the front row yes those go the backwards
however this is just like this is just
like the movies mommy told me a mirror
is what I moved it great or whatever you
call mommy's and uh call them mummies
okay you call them mummies because you
put her in the middle we're using your
mum mum mother mother
do you say mommy everything mother I'd
say mom mom I mean that's my Midwestern
mom I'm like I mispronounced my own name
I don't say grey um I go gram gram wait
how do you say your name
gram is how it's pronounced he'll say it
better than I can gram have I been
saying it wrong all these years
yes Oh bye don't worry about it because
[Laughter]
a soft H no sorry yeah well that's
that's the double American is a gram or
it's gram yeah I I'm I burn it's prep
the way I and most people pronounce it
is like the metric unit of gram yeah you
guys just gotta be honest with ya but
it's pronounced gram I don't hear a
difference do you you guys got a grammar
you just say that gram gram and we take
gram gram gram we hit every sin every
day and so we hit with we're from a
vital s we are front of the mouth we say
about you guys are like back banana back
of the mouth the words national
incidents gonna happen here okay I love
a good a good this thing I love a good
heck or like you know some people get
annoyed when it's like some comedians
maybe some like an old school thing they
go I want to get the big laugh I don't
care there's a fun moment like mo us
chatting to a couple in the front row
and I went where did you guys meet this
is like just been online dating started
and I went this is not in the northeast
of the UK so with the Northeast they've
got like a weird accent like this it's
very playful and it's everyone up
there's all that no one for being
friendly but giving each other like
grief they call Jordi's but you guys
again wouldn't understand [ __ ] so george
already anyway it's a it's a taxi
driver does he dress like a horse racer
anyways just this was so well ty was
like they'd planned it it was the timing
was impeccable as couple how did you
guys meet they weren't online oh really
which web site had this voice in the
back of the room shout out eBay I was
like yes yeah I never won comics kid
like oh I'm always like no [ __ ] that's
that all absolutely I'll let and then
you can jump on and rip with that and
it's great absolutely what's the Geordie
so Judy you know like you said like a
redneck is attorney say for a type of no
he's pointing at the audience yeah so
Judy would be like an area that it's a
northeast of the UK and place called
Newcastle so there's a naturally called
a majority may I don't I don't make the
names up I just a messenger don't share
me literally in America no [ __ ] yeah
that phrase being more pertinent in this
country but I was chance of some guys
yesterday now I do want to I do want to
shoot some guns I feel that's the thing
in a gun range obviously like that's
good yeah you're not just like good luck
in Phoenix yeah some guy said it was
like 20 20 bucks to go shoot some guns
yeah like you're in Arizona it's fine
you're fine
can I ask I was gonna well actually
Halloween's this weekend you might hear
some tonight really there's a vending
machine that just sells guys Yoda is
like obviously is the Brit we kind of
see the news and we just go this is you
go you see what's happened to an
Australia and the UK
sure Matt you know my dad actually shot
he has a shotgun he shoots pheasant
could it be more British in there shoots
pheasants and clay pigeons but so we
have guns I think everyone thinks oh
because of these restrictions you can't
be sto they has it in a cabinet and they
check it every year and has to be used
for the right things but so you know we
still have guns but it's just much more
carefully controlled but as a Brit when
I see the news and I see what horrible
[ __ ] happens you just go we'll just put
those laws in and then it wouldn't
happen and I see that's my rational
brain but now I've got here like I know
that if I went to a gun range I pick up
a gun on me like
it feels good like you just go that but
I bet it feels cool to have a gun I
don't like to get political on this
podcast I am 100% for gun control but
stricter gun control but I had a 22 at 8
like I am guns are fun you had a gun at
the age of 8 at age 8 of 22 at 8 so
that's like yeah that's the south or
Arizona I don't know right backwards hat
like I don't want to get political but I
want to move to Australia yeah you know
we we stood to shoot clay pigeons also
you know clay pigeons are huh lefty
lefty it's like a Jordy that's running
out boys y'all know what clay pigeons
alright alright so we got into really an
icky tune in clay pigeon so we ordered a
gross of clay pigeons through the mail
so heard like three thousand clay
pigeons through the mail eight hundred
of them were intact by the time there's
a box of powder basically I actually
shot the last time I shot a gun was at a
rant a clay pigeon range here in Arizona
with a buddy of mine like 10 years ago
who's a cop the more I want to shoot
like the movies I want to be in a field
and I want to shoot some tin cans and
some bottles off of off a fence that
feels like the best way to does you if I
manage going four minutes just 12
minutes in that voice that kind of sexy
probably the best Beverly Hills Cop film
by a mile there's anything else no no
the best second movie of a comedy yeah
I'm with you and everything else cop 2
is justice ghost Beverly Hills Cop 1 I'd
hate to bring the comedy film nerds of
us to start a fight no though it's a
good thing going because it's a good
point because we talked about this a lot
actually on comedy film nerds comedy
sequels are so hard to pull that
absolutely hang of it suit because they
always try and do the same thing like
tango 2 is the same thing abut in
Thailand but variants cops two's good
because they bring in
yeah like Neal's like they just like
pimped out different different bad guy
minutes brain because it's a cop comedy
it made sense because you just just none
another crime just find it at the rim
crime bring some different people in and
you'll have some comedy and
and it progressed it went from Axel
Foley and Taggart and those guys being
against each other to working together
and they've oh of course they became
friends after they solved the crime
let's take it from there yeah but let's
not talk about Beverly Hills Cop 3
because they're the only the only
redeeming feature is surged in that film
for five minutes we're quite 40 that's
the only thing that's good about it but
the actual plot is that gun he has at
the end I didn't see three I rarely see
a three I draw the line you're not much
you see must have seen see it was I yeah
I that gun is they remember the gun is
it's this surge is like the best gun on
the market and it's got this like normal
gun stuff and then it's got like a boom
box it's huh I mean it doesn't even look
it's got a boom box attached it doesn't
look like a these guys know what a real
gun you should have a boom box on a gun
maybe that would maybe they'll kill
everyone out a bit one of those movies
where they're just like hey let's get
have a party here's a bunch of money and
we'll shoot something the script is 12
pages long just go out there and [ __ ]
around I'll cut something it's 1988 we
got a line in the budget for cocaine
what's with you me and my wife bonded
out we buy for love and I leave a weapon
I'd put two in them it's not comedy but
I put two up there with one for the
comedy you know I don't know I I think
it's more I think it's more of a serious
thing with comedic moments yeah what yet
there's a really good shame black
podcast and he talks about writing he's
funny as [ __ ] shame but haven't taught
he's so funny like this is his podcast
and the writers come on roses and
shouldn't talk about another network on
this one but it's like the notes or
other podcasts yeah anyway I had a
gunner bothering me about it goes or Bud
Light right or Murray yeah talk about
I'm a writer also but what was shamed
out saying he when it comes to being
funny he he needs it to be serious stuff
in it oh yeah oh yeah so he said that he
he can't write comedy with a blank page
he likes it to be serious [ __ ] in it so
when there's a you know it's obvious
about suicide Lethal Weapon
those are funny there's loads of funny
lines in it and it's like funny alright
what's the part of - I don't remember -
is there's a lot yeah it's got the who's
it my mate zombies where I'm working on
a building a house or someone once and
they
just watch leave weapon to and they
would just major laugh every hour by
shouting from one side of the house the
other say with the diplomatic community
this is what just got revoked it's not
mate I love that that's South African
accent in that is dodgy it's so bad
diplomatic it will not hurt like it gets
sillier the longer the film goes on
stuck about racist characters in movies
yes how Bad's get Hank Azaria yeah
what's his face from the undocumented
for a Cisco
Fisher Stevens in short circuit oh my
god yes well short the short circuit
movies are amazing they are they do so
many things so insanely wrong that
they're it it's those movies are so bad
they're fantastic director fantastic to
watch in Fisher Stevens I don't know
what he was doing or what what country
he was supposed to his button is he
doing a mindy under yeah he's doing that
one it's a Hindu who's drinking out of
the pain of stroke here's the thing ago
ago here's the thing he was obviously
very but then in the movie the party
with the great Peter Sellers he did an
English but a Middle Eastern accent but
it was spot-on and didn't it right when
he could have got away with being his
racist threat as he could have been he
didn't spot on and I think it was out
racist
I think his Peter Sellers it was just
kind of brilliant always amazing I don't
know if anyone's ever said that about
Fisher Stevens know
and then one just got Fisher Stevens was
brilliant yeah I'll kick this table over
in the Flamingo kid he was amazed when
him and Matt Damon were trying to score
those girls at the poker room at the
club it was amazing
I'm the only guy that remembers this
movies from 1984 somebody listening is
gonna love this I do love and I eighties
movies are like it's it's very hard fun
with not racist stuff I mean didn't go
in cash that 80s or early 90s
Russell Carosa is almost entirely
everything he says is a little bit
racist towards some with it we got a guy
in the late 80s 80s or 90s one of you
has a computer look it up and I think
I'm gonna guess AC okay 89 88 but yeah
Russell yeah it's just casual this is
that casual but it wouldn't even be seen
as racist at the time but any time it
must be must 989 my favorite racist
character ever Gilligan's Island when
the Japanese military army of Santos is
I'm talking about got lost at sea for
what 30 years I guess would be about
that and his submarine and it's a white
guy squinting with buck teeth and coke
coke bottle glass god that's not racist
at all not at all it was a perfect
depiction of the Japanese well then then
you got to go to breakfast at tiffany's
that another white guy was Mickey you
know Mickey Rooney Mickey Rooney make
you ready maybe not Mickey Rourke and
there's that famous racist character and
diner was horrible Mickey work is just
racist who's that that's Sean Connery
and I'm that James Bond where he becomes
Japanese by putting his hair bun and
just making his eyes narrowed yeah but
he's a spy so it's fine no it's not you
only live twice oh yeah yeah he dies it
gets thrown in the ocean at the
beginning I think that's my first James
Bond movie ever sauce one of the good
ones actually I mean racism aside this
is a weird disclaimer to or something
most the Connery ones are pretty good
yes I know what a James Bond though like
my mates got quite con as a British spy
so love bond but like they are dog [ __ ]
I mean let's let it's it's the same
movie 25 what do you mean are you gonna
roll in my pajamas and talks [ __ ] about
James Bond right now
is that what's gonna scream in a tuxedo
in everyone enjoyed pajamas is bottom
half pajamas top half smart he's dress
for every occasion
oh it's like the mullet of outfits the
money about business of the drug worry
in the back okay got it
sure anytime
but the James Bond isin like I still
like but like the last one what was the
last one it was like two and a half
hours Spectre long and [ __ ] I it was
like the biggest budget and you go
because people love with the familiar
area because their thing on a train and
it wasn't even good I felt that too
after Spectre I was like I don't wear
how much disfranchise how long can we
keep it's cool I mean I like Roger Craig
but I was just like okay Roger Craig
Roger Craig the football player yeah you
mean Daniel Craig Jeff Roger coaching a
bottom yeah but yeah thirty Nelson's TV
show yeah I know coach I was I don't
know wait so gonna behind it funny he
played Patrick and uh spongebob the
other guy
oh the body hair guy meters not
Niedermayer the body her guy help what
one bones one day I'm the only guys fan
George Lazenby's work Her Majesty's
Secret Service is a good bond yeah I
feel it basically got a rough ride cuz
he cried it into that film and I no one
would want to sleep on through that and
I feel like that's wasn't greedy but
this bond finally found true love and
then she's murdered dude it breaks when
we have all the time in the world all
the time in the world gets gunned down
crank
Daniel Craig cried at the end of one
before Spectre Skyfall I know is it
Skyfall one way and again spoiler alert
I think it's Judi Dench died the one
that's home alone mixed with vermin
makes me have fun
isn't that the best you're just like
you're like this is all right not cool a
booby trap in the house I was fully on
board with that I was like just want the
Wet Bandits to come in right now and
this is great
I'll send Joe Pesci's tripping on
marbles
but incidentally there that I home alone
movies again that is there's no there
are great films though there's no home
loan to talking of a beginning on comedy
choose up there with one
I can't adjust to this switch that we
went from bond to home alone being great
I really I just couldn't I just a switch
that we went from the road stories
podcast a comedy film we like that guy
we like I we've got three things going
on at once mixer
David Greta's coming just mixed up
seriously guys had shot first
alright can I tell you over quick can I
tell you a quick what's his name Craig
Daniel Craig no Kirk T Nelson okay no
Daniel Craig story my wife for those of
you who don't know is a costume designer
and she worked on I don't know if I
should be telling this please you know I
guess I could tell her you could if you
if you find out afterward you can call
this live streaming that is true you
know what nah my wife is not a costume
designer good story good everyone we're
moving on so speaking of the road this
is when they when it when we stopped
recording we can then yeah I'll tell I
what was that uh hey welcome come in
have a seat oh please come on in we're
gonna do another hour and a half oh no
we are it's fine come up with more her
she's these foreign people dressed with
one style double-oh-seven
no one's doubled up no one's gone casual
in business everyone's just like uniform
and their outfits right now huh this
guy's dressed correctly he's gone
it's going although there was a time
when ice correct there was a time when
shorts and button-ups and long sleeves
were not acceptable not nowadays no no I
wear that all the time that's my outfit
right there
this is lovely accept her tonight this
where did we lose this weight basically
when you get was a really exciting
teaser to a great story and we have to
carry on and just talk about bloody
movies again you wanna talk about Daniel
Craig
breaking news I'll forget it all right
watch this tie-in I was on the road with
Jimmy Schubert nice yes and we went to
the movies to kill time to see what was
that
who was the
who was uh who's that what would the
movie they had Juno in it but it wasn't
Juno Wow and the director did that movie
my wife worked on you sound like such a
dad right now you're just just a thing
we're just stringing bits in forever you
know this inception inception so you
went to see inception age that's a funny
description of inception I know that
films confusing that was always an
inception confusing disruption well from
Juno it wasn't a juvenile and some guy
like DiCaprio something I don't know he
did something but then that's your
goatee rather than this the film of nine
different levels of dreaming and it
here's the deal we went we ate at the
buffet at the casino for lunch and then
we went to go see inception and we both
got food poisoning and I I don't like to
talk like this but as soon as Juno
walked on the screen I had to poop like
right now not because of her
yeahbsolutely because of her really oh
yeah see that's she has that react Ellen
Page causes no that's funny she's on the
screen I'll be reaching for the tissues
but not not in a good way in quite
horrible way so I split and had to go
and I never saw the rest of Inception I
never saw it so I go to the club that
night and I'm middle in and Schubert's
headlining and I go to the club manager
I'm like oh dude I think I got food
poisoning I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to do a half-hour because you think
I give a [ __ ] about you look at Schubert
and Schubert was passed out on the back
row just about just like throwing up and
like a [ __ ] basket the same club where
you got into the fight and I got into
the fight Wow Wow it all comes around so
never I never never never do this club
you like this [ __ ] yourself we'll get
punched up in Reno the Reno Club yeah
yeah yeah it's gone yeah alright cuz the
food poisoning fights any questions
before we wrap up from the audience
great
what story well when we finished you
heard the story off air yeah I'll tell
you that story later I'm going to hear
this story
remember I was talking about that's all
right I want to thank Scout Mile High
show mr. Matt Santos everywhere can we
could see your pictures okay he's doing
pictures for all things comedy weekend
yeah absolutely
absolutely that's great I want to thank
you guys for coming in hanging out and
chillin with us thanks guys frozen you
don't know this is the road stories
podcast you can catch us on all things
comedy iTunes all the other pod catches
Graham Elwood is comedy film nerds where
can we catch you you can see comedy film
nerds go to comedy films comm we're also
on all things comedy all my tour dates
and everything at Graham Elwood calm my
movie earbuds Murray's hands are in it
Andrew and that's on iTunes and Amazon
and also my other documentary laughs
ganna Stan about me doing performing in
Afghanistan is available on Amazon so go
to Grandma calm you can get all that
awesome that was the best plugging I've
ever heard in my life I was sick
machined and they're not every podcast
all weekend yeah got that down my I'm
called Chris Martin which is really
annoying so have you put Chris Vaughn
comedian I would say comedian into
Google there's like an old American open
mic oh cool Chris mine okay and but yeah
just put it Chris mine comedy code at UK
but you guys don't understand Americans
go there isn't I can't not put comma at
the end you guys don't even it's Martin
don't Hindu don't Hindu Johar back dot
dick on okay crime got it I do progress
will Carlin Chris podcast on all things
comedy calm which is good fun is right
well you're a sky full of stars thanks
man that was most lovely thing anyone's
ever said to me somebody's grandmother
was told about [ __ ] himself two
minutes ago then he's like bloody a poet
Oh Chris Martin you're a sky full of
stars you are have some have some pound
cake before you go yeah that was great
because you gather what the only one
I've heard is yellow so been weird if
you just want Chris you yellow that's
inaccurate hepatitis buddy hepatitis you
on this check box about that joke
they're big Fox News is big Coldplay
fans really do you hear about that
no they [ __ ] [ __ ] all over Radiohead
Colin Radiohead a poor-man's Coldplay
just to show how in touch they are with
reality yes that's the worst thing
foxnews you've ever done screw those
guys guys thank you so much all things
comedy at the all things comedy Comedy
Festival don't read this yeah okay that
was such a great out
please bring Bud Light on stage sure all
right hold on we'll just go with my
alexandra marie scotch instead we're
recording live at the all things comedy
pop-up podcast studio by the way this is
such a great idea people have walked in
to come in is we got a picture window
here people have walked in come in just
enjoyed the shows I've come in and so
we're recording what is going on it
shouldn't be that complicated
oh there we go thank you
thank you oh it's a phoenix style Bud
Light oh the Cardinal of Phoenix
Cardinal go cards right oh just get out
of that I'm not a sports guy we
recording live but the all things comedy
pop-up studio which is awesome I can't
wait to do this again next year we're at
the femur in Phoenix at the all things
comedy festival presented by Bud Light
cityscape and an Tito's handmade vodka
Tito's handmade vodka I'm gonna be
Atlanta next week I don't have you guys
are from Atlanta I'm working the punch
line the hotel I'm staying in only
serves Tito's well as alcohol like what
you can't have a bear no only serves
Tito's all right
so don't be a Geordie and drink tea -
yeah all right I was supposed to read
that at the time just so you know it's
gluten-free so if you if you're looking
to stay in shape guys this is the booze
for you right gluten-free before they
told us gluten special thanks to
stand-up live the Tempe improv and Chico
Malo where we had a fantastic lunch
today oh my god so great I was beat oh
it was awesome I got to tell you and one
of us here runs a festival so I don't
wanna this is a great festive it's a
great festivals it's the first year
it's fantastic it's but it's amazing I
was saying I was telling how magical I
was like so many Trumper
so the Los Angeles I'm a co-producer the
Los Angeles podcast festival we just did
our sixth one name dropper and I was six
I'm named maverick the number six my
buddies sting hates when people name
drop merggle area no calm no I was just
saying like knowing what's involved in
running a festival seeing how smooth
this is and how awesome is it's really
it's I've been having a blast you know
it's almost as smooth as Tito's vodka
vodka on earth guys you guys at Murray
be on Twitter Murray be comedy Atlanta
I'll be at the punchline next weekend
with Josh wolf our buddy Josh wolf
really and I'll be at laughing skull
also off and on for the next couple
months I'm going back and forth from
Atlanta and then I'm hitting the road
heavy in February so guys thanks for
hanging out with us tonight I'll tell
you the story maybe a little Scotch if
you'd like and Chris Martin
very funny comic I love meeting new
comics and of course Graham good friend
of mine we're gonna serve when we get
home all right you guys thanks for
listening on producing thank you so much
thanks Sarah and oh it's like British
scotch
thanks for driving kill this so you can
hear the story